c'est non les français aiment les
escargots
mais les escargots n'aime pas les
français
c'est pourquoi nous devons nous méfier
des escargots qui sous des dehors 20 kg
et bonenfant cache en réalité une âme de
fois on prête à bondy heureusement
heureusement grâce à l'amitié franco
espagnole nous viendrons à bout d
estaing
[Musique]
les espagnols sont un peuple fier et
ombrageux avec un tout petit cul pour
éviter les coups de corne
c'est ce qui fait des espagnols les
meilleurs alliés de la france dans la
lutte contre les escargots
[Musique]
on est allé pour les colimaçons haut
niveau sont ici rigole
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous tenons
c'est non non
[Musique]